hello everyone I do hope you enjoy it
Garry Kasparov's most memorable moments
part 1 as this is part 2 this is a game
from the finals of the rapid tournament
held in Geneva in 1966 and we have
Vishwanathan Anand with the white pieces
against Garry Kasparov and the first two
games they played were in rapid time
format those two games were drawn next
come to blitz games in the first Blitz
game because probably had the white
pieces and the game ended in a draw
after 66 moves so this is Game four of
their final match and Caspar has the
black pieces so it's a definitely an
interesting game and the spiral features
this game as his second most memorable
moment so let's see this game
Anand opens with E 4 and we have c5
Kasper goes for the Sicilian Knight to
f3 d6 we have d4c captures on d4 Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
now a6 the knight of variation and here
we have Bishop to e3 at English attack
Kasparov immediately challenges the
bishop on e3 he plays Knight to g4 we
have Bishop to g5 h6 now Bishop h4 g5
Bishop to g3 and Bishop to g7 this is
pretty much the standard setup for black
when going for the anti English and I've
tried this a couple of times with black
and although it seems reasonable unless
you don't know what you're doing it's
not that even it's not that all too easy
to play it with black so Bishop to e2
now with a double attack on the knight
on g4 and h5 Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now f3 creating a nice
punching here kicking the Bishop from g4
and also making room for the dark square
bishop on f2 so
casparo retreats Bishop to d7 we have
the ship to f2 by Anand and now Knight
to c6 Queen to d2 preparing either
queenside castle or King side castle we
have Knight to e5 by Kasparov and here
under decided to the castle immediately
he cancelled the Kings side although our
waiting move isn't all that bad for
example b3 maybe Knight f5 going for the
bishop on g7 but okay I'm undecided
castle immediately so kingside castle
and the sparrow immediately goes for it
g4 as this is the last game of the Blitz
he does have to try something so he goes
for a g4 we had F for kicking the knight
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen Queen
to e2 and now rook to c8 the developing
the rook and defending the knight and c4
both at once
b3 Knight comes to a3 and now you see
that this knight on h3 does seem a bit
misplaced but with having a rockin see
it as part of actually has some nice
pressure on this c2 pawn we have Knight
to d5 and what's the idea of night to be
Knight to d5
it seems Anand is offering as part of
the play Bishop captures and before
removing the defender of the c2 pawn and
then Casper can obviously freely capture
the pawn and see - so why would under do
something like this
well if Bishop captures on b4 and the
bishop capture some before yes cuz part
of can capture on c2 but after rook
captures now there's this queen - III
move and now you can see that Kasparov's
rook on h8 is also attacked and also
thus Queen Bishop battery is now I'm the
b6 square so you don't have to be
careful where you where you put your
rook because part of probably would have
to play f6 stopping this attack and also
making some room for the king
but then after Bishop to b6 attacking
the Queen Queen to c8 now comes C 5 and
it's it's a very deadly attack for white
it's hard to say probably even winning
let's say Bishop to c6 pawn captures and
now you can't capture the pawn is pinned
so we have to play a six and after rook
a to d1 this is simply simply bad for
black I mean especially especially for a
blades game I don't think black could
defend this so after this Knight to d5
move Kasparov first commonly played east
six kicking away the night we have a
nice to b4 and now comes Queen to a5
attacking that night and before Queen to
e1 defending it and now H for H Bishop
to e3
now comes h3 and here
and loves the position with the g3 we
had night to b5 offering an exchange of
knights and here rook to d1 was played
and this is a this is a bit too slow for
Ireland here you should have played
Knight captures and after Bishop
captures push c4 locking the position
here and and this would have been this
would have been much better than the
position he got himself into after this
night the b5 move he played rook to d1
and here we had Knight to c3 and this is
now not very pleasant for Anand as his
rook is attacked on d1 the pawn is
attacked on e4 and also the queen is
attacking the knight that is now on
defender than before because the knight
is in the way so I don't plays Knight to
b3 now you still can't capture the rook
because your queen will be hanged in an
a5 so Queen back to c7
we have worked the c1 and it doesn't
want to give away the rook and now comes
the knife captures on e4 so Kasparov
snatches upon here we have f5 now and e
5 and here you can see that this night
doesn't have that many squares to go to
the only squared the knight can go to is
actually e2 but if you play Knight to e2
this night can no longer go anywhere it
simply trapped therein in it and it's
cramping on its position so you know you
don't want to play a move like this
so instead after E 5 Anand pushed f6 he
decided to sacrifice another pawn trying
to create something but there really
isn't anything here Kasparov played
Knight captures on f6 and now Knight to
f5 going after the dark square Bishop
Kasparov captured that Bishop captures
rook captures but this now forces a
series of moves that will be deadly
Kasparov plays Queen to c6 immediately
threatening Queen G to checkmate
so on defenseless Queen to e2 and now
comes Queen to e4 again with tempo
attacking the rook on e and F 5 that is
undefended
rook to F 2 an essential move as the
roof has to defend the Queen the Queen
is unprotected and as part of was
threatening the night to Eve 935 but he
goes Knight to d5 either way and he run
on defends with rook to e1 as the
is attacked twice and as you can see in
this position because part of is up two
points he can exchange Queens it's a
completely winning position if he
captures the bishop Knight captures on
e3 and doesn't really have a choice he
has to capture it and then being up two
points it's a completely winning endgame
and here Kasparov thought about Knight
captures on e3 and but he said I'm not
gonna capture with the night I'm gonna
capture with the Queen it leads to the
same and and you know it seems a bit
more forcing so instead of Knight
captures he played Queen captures on e3
expecting Queen captures on e3 but this
is again one of one of his greatest
blunders but okay it's not such a great
blunder since it's a blitz game but by
playing Queen captures on e3 he actually
allowed Queen captures on g4 and I'm
sure you've all seen this video I will
put a link in the description below do
check it out it's the famous the famous
Kasparov blunder face you know where he
goes like this
I don't think I reenacted it precisely
enough so be sure to check the link in
the description it's quite quite a
famous cause prob blunder
so after unplaced Queen captures on g4
he's attacking as far as Bishop on g7
also the rook on c8 is undefended and
also the rook is now attacking the Queen
here a drug can be captured the Knight
is guarding the rook so there really
isn't a good move here whatever you do
you can either capture the rook or or or
something so Casper decided to try
castles on and immediately capture the
Queen rook captures we have Knight
captures rook
I wouldn't attack on allens Queen and
after Queen captures on h3 he played
Knight captures on c2 so he did grab
something for the Queen it's not like he
blundered an entire Queen he does have a
piece and the rook for the Queen but
it's it's simply not enough Queen to d7
going after those Queen side pawns knife
to d4 now Queen captures on b7 a5 we
have King to g2
rook to c3 now attacking the knight
Knights the b2 and now Knight the seat
Knight to c4 now comes d5 Knight to d6
and now Knight to e3 check King 2 H 3
and now f5 so Casper was really trying
he still doesn't want to resign this as
he's gonna put those pawns and try to
create something we had Queen to d7 f4
now Queen to e6 would check King to h7
and the 92 f7 and here now although it
does seem like a spark has quite the
initiative here with the pawn storm in
the center but there's actually a pretty
terrible threat here I've got spiral
continues was something like d4 to
continue pushing the pawn then comes
Knight to g5 check only square for the
king is h8 and now after Queen to g6
there is no defense against Queen to h7
checkmate so unfortunately for casparo
after Knight to f7 he had to play rook
captures on f7 Queen captures and now
again rook to c6 trying to either create
some threats against the black king rock
H it would actually be a pretty nice
move it as it would win the Queen at
checkmate and so on at plays G captures
on f4 making room for his king at g3 we
have rook to f6 now Queen to c7 and E 5
we have f5 d 4 now comes Queen to the
Queen to e7 Rock to h6 check King to g3
and after this night d1 move attacking
the rook we have rook to f4 III now and
again it seems like as part of is very
close but here comes Rock to g4 and in
this position
Gary Kasparov resigned the game because
there is no defense whatsoever against
Queen captures on g7 you could prolong
the game but that's just pointless so
yeah that's the game the 1996 match
between Vishwanathan Anand and Gary
Kasparov which was part of lost in a
completely winning position and this is
featured in his interview as one of his
memorable moments as his second most
memorable moment and I will also put a
link to the entire video it's
interview by New Yorker so be sure to
check that out as well I do hope you
enjoyed it and I don't think I'll be
doing part three of Cosmo most memorable
moments as I already did a video on that
game
it's the game because part of blundered
that I mean it was a terrible blunder
against the deep-blue
the rematch he had against IBM
supercomputer in 1997
so I already did that game so maybe I'll
just change the title of that video to
as far as most memorable moments part
three and I will share it on YouTube
post so you can check it out if you
haven't seen it but I will be doing part
four at some point as it's another
famous game between Kasparov and Karpov
it's from their first match in 1985 and
also it's game 24 so yeah I do I do hope
this will be a nice little series so
once again I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon